well here we are with Logan in World War
2 again and this time he's in the
Pacific Theater just before the atomic
bomb is dropped one question can these
filmmakers make up their mind where
Logan was and what he did so that we can
have something resembling a cannon this
guy is awful at shooting a mass of
purposely freed prisoners no prison can
hold Wolverine except one made of stone
and metal apparently either this isn't a
nuclear blast as I was led to believe or
else this is a sin because this is a
small Bay with a detonation on the other
side it would be like half a second
before the nuclear blast would
incinerate this asshole and everything
on this side of the bay the writer saw
Indiana Jones nuke the fridge and said I
can top that bit who needs adamantium
when you can survive atom bomb heat what
about fallout radiation is the Japanese
guy completely safe because of a piece
of steel or iron that doesn't even cover
him with an airtight seal not that this
is a terrible way to wake up but
flashback within a flashback cliche also
does every movie about Wolverine have to
start with flashbacks also I know this
is a dream again but did they ever even
for this to be a realistic scenario in
his mind I mean we saw them flirting but
she was Scott's girlfriend until she
died then she tried to hump him in the
third movie but he rebuffed her because
she was that Phoenix psycho then she
died again so why are we being shown a
realistic dream where they were a couple
in bed together
Wolverine ception
you're not a hunter are you not anymore
man this thing writes itself angsty hero
tries to live a private life of solitude
but keeps bumping into people who need
saving cliche also don't go to all the
trouble to show him living in a crevice
in a fountain near a remote Yukon town
if you're just gonna wipe all that away
by putting your plot propelling victims
scream within earshot of said crevasse
so he's trying hard to be left alone and
go unnoticed but the death of a fucking
bear sends him over the edge and he just
has to have revenge is this Wolverine or
brave - orgy of evidence that the guy
he's looking for is in this bar you can
hear the music thumping outside the bar
but when Wolverine walks in it's quiet
enough that people can have a quiet
conversation inside the bar also the
girl who's been spying on Wolverine knew
that he would emerge from the woods
tonight and go to this drinking
establishment to avenge his bare
friend's death
I heard was illegal arrow Sheriff Logan
turns over a shot glass with a tiny
amount of liquor in it but then the next
cut shows a lot more booze flowing over
the wound this sword is hundreds of
years old and was named danzan by the
first time I used it movie thinks that
the sword has given some sort of back
story will have Tarantino s credibility
like so I'm pocketing back and naturally
Logan being the sort of person to let
complete strangers tell them what to do
goes with her getting a table I actually
don't see how a knife pretends to
threaten the indestructible Wolverine
but maybe he was just tired of arguing
listen Wolverine is a funny character
okay you don't have to contrive bullsh
it seems like this that the real
Wolverine would never ever let happen
just to get a few laughs okay you look
nice
I feel violated in no way can this bed
be comfortable I can end the eternity
making a water dying old man makes
assumption that a mortal dude wants to
die hey you saved my life I want to
repay you by killing you you're welcome
we have a reason to believe that you
have related to Hugh can be passed ask
from you to another well I hope the
writers also remembered to include a
convenient reason why this technology
can never be used to get also
superpowers and alcohol stones or herpes
is Tschida place the pronoun game so
that Logan has to ask who the hell he's
talking about
human drama plays out exactly as Logan
is leaving so that he has to get
involved moving mistakenly thanks famke
janssen flashbacks will somehow help
this character has way too much
importance to the story to actually be
dead so we're sure to see him later when
the movie needs a surprise I realize it
may have been raining recently but it is
pretty fucking far from raining right
now so why do all these members of the
crowd still have their umbrellas up why
are you still here you don't care about
this dead asshole remember does he think
nobody can see him wait does the movie
think nobody can see him who's that
Marek oh nothing about this guy stands
out as anyone special but Logan asks who
he is so that we can get some exposition
on a character who will be important
later and he was always fascinated video
kind that's racist definite possible
future love interest is definite Jesus
this ninja protector weirdo dude doesn't
even have his primary weapon ready
Legolas and Hawkeye would both already
have fired 35 arrows by now
Louie rips off the trained assassin
follows crucial kidnapping by rooftop in
order to help save the day thing from
the Bourne Ultimatum
stalking at some point Logan stopped and
bought a ticket for this train which is
unlikely or he just showed his metal
claws to the people in charge and they
gave him a seat if so what a hobo
marinas become so where are we headed
Mariko because I sure as hell didn't buy
a ticket to this Logan just assumes the
role of this chick's protector after the
chase because reasons you can't pretend
it isn't happening when it is princess
unless you want to die okay so maybe
everyone speaks only Japanese on this
train but what a horrible discussion
this is to have across the aisle for
anyone to hear Wow
what the hell indeed if Wolverine has
been given some sort of drug that makes
him moral again wouldn't the bullets
kill him instead of just wounding him I
sure hope this isn't going to be one of
those we were only able to do half the
procedure type deals that are ultra
convenient Yakuza guys managed to find a
way to the exact Train Wolverine Americo
hopped on even though they were way
behind earlier also these guys brought
guns to a claw fight hero fighting on a
train looks up just in time to see
something that will decapitate him
cliche hero fighting on a train looks up
just in time to see something that will
decapitate him cliche again video game
action sequence what are you still doing
here
you were done being the hero Jean Grey
is the hottest annoying ghost in film
history Jean Grey gets the preposition
wrong he's just a man now his flesh is
weak now yeah now with Logan gets
multiple gunshot wounds he can only
stand up for 12 hours before someone
finally needs to take him to the
hospital what a pussy and I expect you
to understand you're not Japanese that's
racist
I see Americo took hiding out lessons
from Sarah Connor and makes a phone call
that a dangerous both Logan and her we
now take you to the lumberjacking
portion of this movie please can you
offer the gift after you get out of the
well this movie feels like we're in the
ninth season of a TV show called
Wolverine and they've run out of ideas
so they make him go to a faraway country
and he learns existentialism one way to
get Jean Grey out of your dreams is to
start kissing Asian girls you hardly
know or not the bad guys were able to
kidnap America without alerting Logan
what are the Yakuza guys ninjas know I
need to tell you something doing no so
she just drives all this way without
going ahead and telling him to something
Logan well I'll be damned
she did drive that whole way in silence
before telling him to something I saw
you die prediction of the future that
the main character is going to die is
totally useless putting your own heart
in your head still beating well I would
hope his heart isn't beating if he's
holding it in his hand
that would be super wrong Wolverine can
just walk into the important and
mob-connected Navarro's penthouse while
he's sexing hookers yeah
record scratch noise and the music goes
off when the main character interrupts a
party cliche oh oh yes English that's
racist
Wolverine straight up tries to murder a
dude I need to tell you all this because
it's important to know why you're going
to get slapped we interrupt this
Wolverine movie to bring you the last
samurai ninjas who silently and
stealthily kill all the other people in
the compound without raising any
suspicion swarm in an obvious visible
pack prior to capturing the one guy they
actually came here for a viper discount
poison ivy these assholes walk right
past a dead fucking body but the
slightly ajar door is reason to pause
with concern was smashing through the
glass necessary I don't know what that
green spit she put on the pen was but
the pen stab to the neck alone didn't
kill this guy
yes let's waste time in a Wolverine
movie trying to make the audience think
the main character is going to die again
ridiculous samurai sword fight in home
medical facility somehow doesn't damage
any of the crucial medical equipment
live with that movie makes sure the bad
guy attacks the good guy one last time
so the good guys morally justified in
killing up two shots of Logan's stopping
his motorcycle in the snow to look at
his destination within a minute and a
half of each other check back in 45
seconds when we do it again I don't know
what's less believable but she can see
there's get going on from way up here or
that she even heard it in the first
place to come running to the free window
is there any reason why he can't just
cut a bunch of these off we need to fill
five minutes with something to give this
movie a little more runtime oh why don't
just have them shoot arrows at him the
whole time
see when you commit all your ninjas to
the Wolverine capture you have no one
left to even spot this chick walking
right up to the gate wait on second
thought Logan is already inside a wake
from his coma
so that was like an hour or more ago so
there should definitely be ninjas out
here patrolling and seeing pink haired
motorcycle chicks approaching the
compound I don't know much about the
silver samurai from the comics but I
know everyone that I know who loves the
silver samurai hates this movie for what
it did to silver samurai I see the
silver samurai to wait patiently for
these three to exchange looks over a
dead poison chick before continuing his
pursuit because when a reptile sheds its
skin it can somehow survive an arrow to
the chest all right this chick finally
got interesting oh never mind why is the
silver samurai calmly stalking his prey
instead of just killing him
yes let's leave the guy you're fighting
to go after the guy shooting harmless
arrows at you makes perfect sense also
how the long is this movie gonna wait
before showing us the old man inside the
silver samurai suit
Bob Logan believes it's best to announce
your presence when you have the upper
hand in a fight
also look Harada shot this guy in the
eye with an arrow and there was clearly
blood coming from the opening then
Wolverine chopped dude's head off but
now it looks like this is exactly where
his head was supposed to be the whole
time is if the helmet was just there for
show don't look so shocked I am NOT
shocked and transfer your unwanted
healing to my body drilling into Logan's
claws transfers his superpowers because
genetics let's talk about yashida's plan
plan a was to ask Wolverine if he wanted
to transfer his healing properties and
live a mortal life
Wolverine turned that down Plan B fake
your own fucking death for no reason
look they had Wolverine right where they
needed him this green stuff made him
sleepy then Viper kissed heart weakening
parasites into his body he was basically
mortal all they had to do was strap the
guy down go to a lab and steal his
powers job done instead the movie wants
to have this big not a surprise with
Yoshida faking his death which opened up
a billion unneeded complications you
know I'm giving you the very death you
long tour
haha that is funny I buried my
grandfather even though Yoshida sucked
out pretty much all of Wolverines
immortality a couple of stab wounds are
gonna still kill him you asked me to
come say goodbye sayonara that's racist
don''t damn Jean Grae has to steal
another scene because star power that
main character forgives himself and the
ghost goes away cliche so what do you
want to go Lucy interesting not really
but it's upsetting that something
interesting might happen in this movie
off-screen why would a military
contractor like Trask industries
advertise on the televisions that hang
in the security area of airports I mean
the only reason I can think of is we're
trying to be cutesy and shoehorn in a
little tease of things to come and
that's just not good enough magneto
gives away his presence with magnetic
weird everyone can see instead of just
tapping Logan on the shoulder also other
than looking cool is there any reason
this conversation needed to take place
at the security checkpoint or even in an
airport for that matter why not outside
in the cab Logan took to get here or in
the diner where he ate his breakfast
this morning
uh Dark Horse's over here this is where
Gandalf and magneto officially became
the same character this is I now amazing
right Professor X was dead at the end of
x-men The Last Stand but the end credits
scene showed he would live again on
question though how can you come back
from the dead but still need a
wheelchair
getting a time
I don't was you Fredo Boris you're found
a way to meet the tempests of dear Tommy
how's the peeping Tommy to me I can't
adjust english mother do you speak it
as I told lady freeze when I pulled her
plug this is a one-woman show you want
answers I got the truth